se intensifican las utilidades en
mianmar este martes estallaron los
enfrentamientos en el estado de karen en
el sureste del país luego de que la
guerrilla étnica unión nacional karen
tomarán puestos del ejército birmano
cerca de la frontera tailandesa en
respuesta a la junta militar golpista
está lanzando ataques aéreos sobre
posiciones de los insurgentes provocando
el desplazamiento de cientos de locales
la junta militar lanzó ataques aéreos en
el área de la brigada 5 del kn el martes
por la tarde según los medios locales el
ataque se produce después de que el kn
capturar a una base de la junta militar
en la frontera entre tailandia y mianmar
hoy por la mañana la unión nacional
karen ha aumentado sus operaciones en
las últimas semanas como respuesta a la
violenta represión de las
manifestaciones prodemocracia por parte
del taimado que dejan más de 750
fallecidos desde el golpe de estado
militar del 1 de febrero que ha desatado
una crisis social y humanitaria en
mianmar cantando en birmano su
disposición de luchar por el pueblo unos
120 jóvenes se estarían entrenando con
las guerrillas étnicas para hacer frente
a la violencia de los militares
se autodenominan como fuerza de defensa
unida formada por ex manifestantes
antigolpistas que cansados de las
masacres del ejército se habrían
levantado en armas ex manifestantes en
mianmar se están entrenando con grupos
étnicos armados para enfrentarse a la
junta militar después de huir de las
sangrientas represiones este grupo se
llama a sí mismo la fuerza de defensa
unidad las últimas hostilidades se
producen días después de que el jefe de
la junta militar asistiera una cumbre
regional de la asean donde acordó poner
fin a la violencia y entablar el diálogo
pero las manifestaciones continúan
replicándose en otras regiones del país
pidiendo la liberación de los presos
políticos el fin de la represión y la
restauración de la democracia